[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est le lancement du hac at
on exploite génération c'est le deuxième
à quatre portes est complètement par le
proto 204 c1 à caton donc 48 heures de
créativité porté par le pays à paris
saclay et le salon à outils word qui
rassemble des professionnels des objets
connectés
le music on s'est donné un peu comme
l'année dernière c'était de rassembler
des étudiants logis des usagers en
général de paris saclay pour essayer de
les faire avancer en 48 heures sur une
expérience me faire usage et comment est
ce qu'on peut améliorer l'expérience et
j'ai sur certaines thématiques à travers
un prototype du ski soit si ce n'est
fonctionnel mais en tout cas qu'on
puisse toucher qui démontre un usage et
de la méthode essaie de travailler sur
une forme d'accélération c'est à dire
sans forcément les obliger à faire une
start-up derrière o2 qu'à s'inspirer des
méthodes là à la fois sur le modèle
économique sur la communication et
notamment et principalement une
peut-être sa grande lusage parce qu'avec
ses participants qu'on a un qui nous
font le plaisir de venir là pendant 48
heures qu'ils soient étudiants designers
chercheurs mais coeur industriel
ils ont tous en commun cette compétence
d'ingénierie à ces avancées sur les
technologies donc ça ils ont prescrit
nativement et nous ne parte notre
travail c'est de leur apporter cette
question de l' usage du modèle
économique du design pour faire en sorte
qu'on passe d'un prototype pas une
espèce de prêts produits en tout cas -
vue d'opérer cette magie là dans un
temps assez courant
ce hackaton il a trois thématiques cette
année c'est la e-santé il ya un volet
spécifique sur les seniors soir comment
est-ce qu'on aide ces nouvelles
personnes dans l'environnement la
mobilité à paris saclay c'est important
mais aussi autre part comment est-ce
qu'on peut accompagner et puis le smart
building la domotique les bâtiments
intelligents est ce qu'on peut en
inventer une bonne interaction autour de
ces interfaces que sont les bâtiments
après on continue à les soutenir parce
que paraît s'est classée 1re innovation
prix world
donc on va les soutenir notamment en les
mettant dans le bus le fameux proto bus
on a envie de faire de présenter ces
prototypes la auprès des habitants les
ag de paris-saclay notamment à des
pollutions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]